so we're given this function f of x and
it equals this rational expression over
here and we're asked what does f of x
approach as x approaches negative
infinity so as x becomes more and more
and more and more negative what does f
of x approach and like always pause the
video and see if you can think about
that on your own
well one thing that i like to do when
i'm trying to consider the behavior of a
function as x gets really positive or
really negative is to rewrite it so
f of x i'm just rewriting it once is
equal to 7
x squared minus 2 x
over
15 x
minus 5.
now an interesting technique to think
about what happens to the different
terms as x gets very positive or x gets
very negative
is to divide both the numerator and the
denominator by the highest degree term
of x in the denominator and the highest
degree term of x in the denominator is
the first degree term we just have we
have just a single x there so let's
multiply both the numerator and the
denominator
by one over x or another way of thinking
about is we're dividing both the
numerator and the denominator by x and
if we're doing the same thing to the
numerator and the denominator if we're
multiplying or dividing them by the same
value i should say well then i'm just
really just multiplying it by one so i'm
not changing its value but this will
make it a little bit more interesting a
little bit easier for us to think about
what happens when x becomes very very
very negative
so 7x squared divided by x or being
multiplied by 1 over x is going to be 7x
2x times 1 over x or 2x divided by x is
just 2
and then all of that over
15x
divided by x or 15x over x is just going
to be 15
and then you have 5 over x 5 times 1
over x is equal to 5
over x minus 5 over x
now this is
this is equivalent for our purposes to
what we started with but it makes a
little bit easier to think about what
happens when x gets very very very very
negative
well when x gets very very very very
very very negative
this is going to become a very large
negative number you subtract 2 from it
it really won't matter much you divide
that by 15 well that's not going to
matter much and this is just going to
become very very very small you're
taking 5 and you're dividing it by ever
larger negative numbers or more and more
negative numbers so this right over here
is going to go to 0. this thing over
here is going to go towards infinity and
if you or i should say it's going to go
towards negative infinity 7 times you
know for
7 times a negative trillion 7 times a
negative google seven times a negative
google plus we're getting more and more
negative numbers this is going to get
this is going to approach negative
infinity it doesn't matter that you're
subtracting 2 from that in fact that'll
get even more negative it doesn't matter
if you then divide that by 15 you're
still approaching negative infinity if
you had negative if you had a
arbitrarily
negative number you divided by 15 you
still have an arbitrarily negative
number
and so you could say that this is going
to go to
negative infinity now another way that
you could have thought about it
and this is actually how i do think
about it when i'm trying to
when when i'm when i see these types of
problems i say well what are which which
terms in the numerator and the
denominator are going to dominate and
what do i mean by dominate well as x
gets very positive or x gets very
negative another way to think about it
as the magnitude of x gets large the
absolute value of x gets large the sec
the higher degree terms are going to
grow much faster than the lesser degree
terms and so we could say that for
for large x
for
large
for large x and when i say up
large i mean high absolute value
high
absolute value and if we're going to
negative infinity that's high absolute
value
so f of x is going to be approximately
equal to the highest degree term on the
top which is 7x squared divided by the
highest degree term on the bottom 15x is
going to
grow in fact this is right over here is
constant so as this becomes larger and
larger and larger this is going to
matter a lot lot less so it's going to
be approximately that
which is
equal to
7 x over 15. well even here think about
what happens when x becomes very very
negative here well you're just going to
get larger you're going to get more and
more and more negative values for f of x
so once again f of x itself is going to
approach is going to go to
negative infinity as x goes to negative
infinity let's do another one of these
so here they're telling us to find the
horizontal asymptote of q
and you could find
a horizontal asymptote you could think
about it as what is the function
approaching as x becomes as x approaches
infinity or as x approaches negative
infinity and just as a couple of
examples here it's not necessarily the
one i'm
q of x that we're focused on but you can
imagine a function let's say it has a
horizontal asymptote at
at y is equal to
2. so that's y is equal to 2 there let
me draw that line so let's see it has a
horizontal asymptote like that well then
the graph could look something like this
it could look
it could let me draw a couple of them
that have horizontal asymptotes
so maybe it's over here it does some
stuff but as x gets really large it
starts approaching
it the function starts approaching that
y equals 2 without ever quite getting
there and it could do that on this side
as well as x becomes more and more
as x becomes more and more negative
as more as it gets more negative
approaches it without ever getting there
or it could do something like this
you could have
if it has a vertical asymptote too it
could look something like this
where it approaches
it approaches the horizontal asymptote
from below as x becomes more negative
and from above
and from above as x becomes more
positive or vice versa or vice versa so
this is just a sense of what a
horizontal asymptote is it's really
what's the behavior what value is this
function approaching as x becomes really
positive or x becomes really negative
well let's just think about it we can
essentially do what we just did in that
last example
what happens if we were to
if we were to divide all of these terms
by the highest degree term in the
denominator
well
if we divide
so q of x is going to be equal to
the highest degree term in the
denominator is x to the ninth power
so we could say
six
six x to the fifth divided by x to the
ninth is going to be six over
x to the fourth
and then minus 2 times
x to the ninth
all of that over
3
over i'm going to divide this by x to
the 9th x to the 7th
plus 1.
well if x approaches positive or
negative infinity six divided by
arbitrarily large numbers that's going
to go to zero
two divided by arbitrarily large numbers
whether they are positive or negative
that's going to go
zero go to zero so your numerator is
clearly going to go to zero this term of
the denominator three divided by
arbitrarily large numbers whether those
large whether we're going in the
positive or the negative direction it is
going to get is going to approach zero
it'll approach zero from the negative
direction if we're approaching if our or
we could say from below if if we're
dealing with
very negative x's if we're dealing with
very positive x's then we're going to
approach 0 from above we're going to get
smaller and smaller positive values so
all of these things go to zero and this
right over here is going to be would
stay at one and so if you're approaching
zero in your numerator and approaching
one in your denominator the whole thing
is going to approach zero so in the case
of q of x you have a horizontal
asymptote at y is equal to zero i don't
know exactly what the graph looks like
but we could draw a horizontal line at y
equals zero and it would approach it it
would approach it from above or below
let's do one more
what does f of x approach as x
approaches negative infinity
well let's divide all of these let's
divide all of these terms by the highest
degree that we see in the denominator we
see an x to the fourth so
3x to the fourth divided by x to the
fourth is 3
minus 7 over x squared i'm just dividing
by x to the fourth minus 1 over x to the
fourth
over
x to the fourth divided by x to the
fourth is 1 minus 2 over x plus 3 x to
the fourth this is an equivalent this
right over here is for our purposes for
thinking about what's happening on a
kind of an end behavior as x approaches
negative infinity this will do i've just
divided everything by x to the fourth
and so what's going to happen is x
approaches negative infinity this is
going to approach zero this is going to
approach zero this is going to approach
zero and this is going to approach zero
and so as all of that stuff approaches
zero what we're left with is we're going
to approach
we're going to approach 3 over 1 or we
could say just 3.
another way you could think about doing
these
is look at the highest degree terms 3x
to the 4th x to the 4th ignore
everything else because they're going to
be overwhelmed by these higher degree
terms so you could say f of x is
approximately equal to 3x to the fourth
over x to the fourth
four
large
large magnitude x
magnitude x and very negative is still a
very large magnitude large absolute
value and so 3x to the fourth divided by
x to the fourth
f of x is going to be approximately
equal to three or it's going to approach
three so that's another way that you
could think about it